the largest tv news network in the
philippines has had to lay off hundreds
of workers and massively curtail news
operations
after lawmakers voted to reject its
license renewal
abs-cbn has shuttered 53 of its regional
television and radio stations
leaving only its cable operations in the
capital manila
untouched the network had in the past
been highly critical of president
rodrigo duterte
and his so-called war on drugs the
curtailment of its operations
has been described as a black day for
independent media
in the country
a death knell for media freedom in the
philippines
for decades abs-cbn
broadcast vital information to isolated
communities
through its regional network now it has
been forced to slash its operations
leaving millions of filipinos without a
crucial source of local news
there will be many filipinos in rural
provinces
who will no longer have access to
accurate information
and that's where the issue of press
freedom comes in
laid off workers and members of the
public gathered outside the broadcaster
in manila
to mourn the loss of the regional
stations
they also added their names to a
petition launched by a group of citizen
volunteers
the group hopes to collect seven million
signatures
and push congress to renew the broadcast
franchise
i grew up watching abs abs-cbn as a
child
i love this network their programs keep
me company
and entertain me when i come home from
work tired
it makes me cry when i think about
abs-cbn not being allowed to operate
[Music]
actually i feel a mix of emotions
it will be hypocritical to say that we
are not angry with those who killed our
franchise
but we believe that the day will come
that we will be allowed to be back
on air again
the media freedom watchdog reporters
without borders says journalism in the
philippines has been under increasing
attack
since president rodrigo duterte came to
power
abs cbn is one of the most high-profile
casualties
maria resa is editor-in-chief of the
news site rappler
and knows a thing or two about earning
the displeasure of the duterte
government he joins me now
on the line from manila maria i'd like
to
uh ask you first about abs-cbn
place it in context for us what does it
mean for the average filipino
it is the largest broadcaster in the
philippines
it's radio stations reach parts of the
philippines that no other
news group hits it is also known as the
star network its entertainment group is
huge uh it's the star network right
so news entertainment uh it is a company
that employs
11 000 people uh and to have this
uh shut down is a huge blow and
definitely meant to be a cautionary tale
for journalists
where does this leave independent media
in the philippines maria
an endangered species you know uh all of
the cases against me and rappler
in 2018 there were 11 filed by the
philippine government
uh and then the arrest warrants that
have gone through the can
one conviction on june 15th this year
all of this is just
one journalist and one small group right
it was a cautionary tale
but to shut down abs-cbn is
unthinkable before the time of covid in
fact the last time it happened was in
1972
when ferdinand marcos declared martial
law and the network was shut down for 14
years
you know so is this bringing forward
another
decade or so of a dictatorship
this is a question in the minds of
filipinos and frankly
for journalists to shut shutdown abs-cbn
is tremendous power
this is what we're up against what do
you think
maria are things going to get far worse
under the detector government
i think it already has if you look at
what coven 19 has done right
we have had the longest lockdown this is
the 24th
week of a lockdown that is largely
driven by
security forces and we have incidents of
kovitz still exponentially
increasing meantime as early as april 1
you have president duterte
telling security forces to shoot anyone
who violates
quarantine rules this is uh not a good
way to deal with that
having said that in the middle of the
pandemic on may 5th
a small regulatory group issued this
order to shut down abs-cbn
our house of representatives a working
committee there then took away the
franchise voted against it
so you can see that we have at least a
captured legislature
it is we're on the precipice fighting
for our democracy
maria risa we'll have to leave it there
for the time being but thank you so much
for joining us
you